uh
so i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna go over a
couple of projects today
both optical uh one of them you can see
one of them you cannot see
i have some samples here the one you can
see and the one you
can't see so this is probably going to
be more interesting
if you can if you don't have see-through
vision so
uh as michael mentioned uh 3d printing
is something that's
kind of well and truly arrived i just
got back from ces and
it was a real sort of fiesta of
different companies that are coming out
with different 3d printing and it's
really uh
sort of has its own zone at cs this year
so it's
it's it's really arrived will i am was
recently announced as the sort of
chief creative officer for 3d systems so
that gives you any indication of what's
going on
out there in 3d printing industry it's
really interesting so but if we look at
it from i guess
the research side uh not many
people are sort of too familiar i think
with things that are going on in the
industry to really scale
3d printing up so this is one example of
a
really large mass production prototype
uh
by a research institute in the
netherlands uh called tno
and it's this concept uh that the you
know in the process of fabricating
uh to create you know individual objects
really really quickly
uh that are all different and creating
them on this sort of production line
so this this sort of hasn't really gone
uh unannounced
uh you know by some really high up
people
and there's a big sort of movement i
think to really bring back uh
the making uh the manufacturing and
doing things like
in a new and really different way right
here
so printed optics and and i think the
work i'm going to talk about today is
this this
movement from assembling these
individual you know pieces
and to make a device uh how do we go
from that from being assembled
to being printed in their entirety
and that's that's kind of no no easy
feat
but i'm going to talk about one specific
area of work i've done
in this space and that relates to
using optics and this is a commercially
available
material printed on a commercially
machine with a lot of sort of hand
sanding afterwards
but that gives you some sort of idea of
what you can get out of
the technology that exists today so
the first project is work i did while i
was at disney research in pittsburgh
and at carnegie mellon with my
collaborators eric brockmeyer
scott hudson and yvonne puprev
so this work looks at three different
areas
the first one being different types of
displays
we can create with optical material
the second one being different types of
sensors we can make for input
i again using optical material and
finally
different types of illumination we can
we can uh we can create just from a
design perspective using this material
so i'm going to go through these uh one
by one
so we basis on a number of sort of
technical things we can do
in terms of how we can guide and reflect
light
and the first of those is is dealing
with uh light pipes which are basically
you know fiber optic-like structures
that instead of being created with you
know conventional manufacturing
techniques
we actually just make from a software
file so this is a
couple of different materials we use uh
you can see the structure here
you shine the light on one side and
basically the materials are such that
the light internally reflects and it can
bend around corners
um this is a animation here
we didn't quite figure out how to how to
slow down light
that would have been pretty cool but uh
this is the internal structure so you
can see that
it's much like a regular fiber optic
cable it has this sort of core
and there's cladding around it which has
a different index of refraction
and then of course we can add an
arbitrary sort of case around that that
can take on any shape
and of course uh this is work done at
disney so
no better shape to use than some cute
little character
so we looked at how we could make these
sort of snap-on displays for
in this case mobile projectors so this
is a little
uh little character here um
i'm not sure if we want to pass these
around
and check them out later on and
basically we can
project a little eyes of the character
ask it really important questions uh
and it can respond so
the idea here is that really we can
basically map a display to any surface
on an object uh basically by you know
projecting into the bottom of it
but also we could you know take another
form factor which would be a
in this case it's a tabletop display but
it could be you know your ipad or
whatever
and and map that light that's kind of
being blocked by the object
uh onto another surface that's visible
so this is a one example
of a a little
chess chess game and you're displaying
uh you know the the
location of the pieces on the on the
piece itself
so we add some little
tags to the bottom of these optical tags
and we can basically track and project
onto that that location
where the chess piece is
so another another technique we use to
guide and reflect light is these
tiny internal reflectors that sit inside
of this uh
you know piece of polished plastic
so these basically again this is a
animation just to show but basically
they reflect light that that is uh you
know shined
into that piece uh and basically what we
can do is we can
sort of map these out into a
three-dimensional space such that
uh each of these each of these little
bubbles and this
object can be uh you know addressed
individually from a 2d
projector so we're doing a you know
really simple example simple prototype
this is what it looks like as you're
looking through this sort of field of
bubbles we can basically hit those and
bounce the ball around
so it's it's a really a simple proof of
concept but you know it kind of opens up
the space of how you can
design the inside of these objects as
well so these these
these shapes don't just need to be
little bubbles they can actually be
tubes and a few other shapes as well so
we can also make other characters that
have
uh the you know little shapes inside of
them in this case it's a little hot
and basically you can put it on top of a
little led
and it's hot it's gonna going to beat
inside
you know just uh like that
so the next next category is about
sensors
and we're really looking here at how we
can basically design
uh these objects so that they can not
only display the content but we can take
input from uh from the user and
interpret that so we created a whole
bunch of different ways of
working with light and optical sensors
so that we can
sense you know simple things such as you
know the push of a button
so here uh light is being
shown along this led from an led through
this uh
waveguide i guess and into a little
photo detector on the other side and
basically this creates this really nice
analog
reading and you can basically get a nice
little sensor
so this essentially comes out of the
printer you insert these two
basic uh little uh sensors or led and a
photo transistor into it
and then you can create any number of
different uh
motion sensing devices so you know these
could be dials could be sliders
uh could be uh even this sort of crude
optical accelerometer
so there's many different things you can
can do with that uh
you can also through another slightly
different approach you can
sense touch and so this is using a light
that that sort of shines
through this plastic body and basically
reflects some amount of light back into
the sensor
and gives you a touch input on a 3d
printed
surface so you know one example is to
make a little gain controller
you can you know insert your little
sensors inside of it
during the printing process and
basically that makes it this really
really
robust little object and of course you
can
sense the touch input on each of those
surfaces
the final final category of work is is
really looking at
more the design perspective and how we
can you know guide and reflect light to
make you know
things that look pretty so one of the
ways we do this is by inserting
leds into into these objects and
i have a few examples up here you can
check out
the the basic process is such that
uh you can make you know
different shapes inside of these these
these objects to
to spread light out focus it in or split
it in in a couple of different
directions
and you can see we we do this
by uh you know
first of all starting with some digital
file uh
and then stopping the printer uh in the
in
sort of mid mid print start inserting
these leds
and then go ahead and like close it up
and
the end product after you've sort of
sanded this down a little bit is this uh
this is the structure here so based on
that
um we created like a range of different
light bulbs
that are the sort of play on the you
know what a conventional light bulb is
is going to look like
um so there's a couple examples here but
basically uh these are
you know regular led attachments and of
course like a light bulb doesn't really
need to look like a light bulb if it's
um like an edison light bulb uh we're
inserting these
tiny little bubbles into it to create
you know unique uh reflections inside of
the object
uh you know having little light pipes
that are gonna bend the light around
inside as well as uh you know
you know this is the the the tribute to
edison here of uh you know making a
for example a solid block that can have
a design all of itself inside of it
so again the the process here is we're
sort of using
different software to set the location
of these these individual
uh bubbles inside of the object and then
we have this uh
hardware that's built into that that we
insert so basically we can attach these
really easily to any
any uh light bulb uh and this is the
sort of sped up 3d printing process
uh and then of course at the end it sort
of there's we haven't really figured out
a really
great way to just sand these things down
so that that part of it
is still uh still done manually
but the end product at the end is is
this
you know pretty clear object that you
can you know polish up and then
attach to the light bulb
so it's it's great looking at this you
know
at high speed because it took so much so
much time to like
to sand that down it's like um so
there's a number of obviously
technical issues uh that occur with
the approach we're doing for the light
pipes for example so
uh the resolution of the you know
current generation printers
is is still limited uh so you know if
you look at a cross section of
of these pipes you can see that you know
the the circles
are not circular uh and the tubes are
not really tubular
so everything is is very rough so as a
result you know you
the transmittance you get from a 3d
printed light pipe is is really
nowhere near on the level of commercial
optical fiber which is just almost like
99.999 percent
so um you're not going to send uh you
know
transact atlantic communication with
this but i think for the purpose of
making small objects it works
you know reasonably well uh we also
developed a number of different
techniques for
for smoothing the surface of of of of
these objects
um and this works you know for really uh
low profile things but it's it's
difficult if it's a much larger object
so obviously you can see like this is an
example of some 3d printed
little lenses and each of these is like
about five five millimeters
in diameter uh
so i'm going to switch up gears now and
talk about another project
called infrastructure and this is what i
worked on with andy wilson
at microsoft research and this is kind
of still this
idea of using optical sensing
and the idea of using you know new
fabrication techniques
uh to enable you know different types of
interaction with with computers
uh and it's really motivated by this
this uh
this problem of how objects are made
right now and like mass produced in
these sort of
i'm not saying mass produced but like
produced in these sort of 3d printing
factories so this is like how shapeways
literally
uh goes about like creating you know a
whole bunch of 3d printed objects so
they
they have this sort of powder process
and they're literally like pulling these
objects out of this huge stack
of powder um and all of these things
like some of them you know look really
really similar
uh they're all the same color they're
going to get lost
and then after that they get uh you know
put in this
like post-processing to smooth them out
like sand them down basically
uh and so anyway at the end of this like
i don't know how they how they keep
track actually
they have to keep track of these things
somewhere and the guy actually told me
that when i
when he came up to me after giving a
talk at sugraph he was like
the way we actually keep track of these
is like by weighing them so like we have
an object we have a kind of like a rough
guess of how much it weighs
and that's like really terrible so
there's this kind of crazy amount of
logistics involved in like tracking
these individual objects and this hasn't
really existed before because
in in typical manufacturing you get 100
of the same thing or a million of the
same thing out it doesn't really matter
which is which
whereas here it's like it actually
matters they're all look very similar
so the motivation here is like how do we
figure out a way of uh identifying these
objects and like
and if we can if we can identify them i
mean that's great just for these
purely uh logistical purposes but
on top of that you know there's
interesting ways we can interact with
them
so one of the interesting things you can
do with 3d printing is to actually use
the internal geometry right so you can't
really
define internal geometry
through any other manufacturing process
with any amount of reliability right so
you can't you know injection mold an
eiffel tower inside of a
inside of something else it's not doing
that with any accuracy
is really difficult so if we combine
that with the ability to see inside of
the objects you know i was thinking
some interesting things you could do in
terms of embedding information in these
objects
and this particular project looks at
sort of
the very very end of the optical
spectrum which is this uh
tear hertz range which is between you
know radio waves and optical
uh and basically uh you know tear hurts
imaging it looks like this if you take
your little pcb circuit board if you
cover it
with a uh you know layer of uh plastic
that's
you know invisible and infrared it
essentially creates this this time
domain image of multiple reflections
uh you know reflecting back from that
object so
you can see it's kind of a volumetric
data set
which is really really interesting and
the basic principle is is
is it sends out this emitted signal
uh from each layer it bounces uh bounces
back a reflection
uh and essentially you can you can use
that to sort of recover
some structure inside of the object uh
so what these machines look like you
know they're super expensive they're
kind of like used for industrial
purposes of quality control
um is essentially like it looks like a
projector it looks like a little
projector
and you can put your uh for example
object and we call this a sort of
infrastruct tag and this is an object
that has
a bunch of different layers inside of it
if you put that underneath this
underneath this this see-through scanner
you can recover this uh
the data you're seeing here that's this
volumetric stack if you like
so the thought here is that if we can
actually encode uh kind of defects
into this into the 3d printed object
then we can
you know obviously we can fabricate that
with 3d printing and then we can you
know
recover that using uh using this
see-through scanning technique and the
basic idea is that
we have the defects are essentially a
difference in index refraction so you
have this sort of high material which is
a higher
higher refractive index material and a
low material
and just sort of put as bits inside of
an enclosure and essentially
this gives you back this this nice
little signal
uh that that gives a pulse a sort of
strong reflection where there's
a one and basically sort of not really
much of a reflection when there's a zero
and we went about sort of designing a
bunch of different tag designs
that could uh could potentially you know
be used for different purposes
so these tags are you know some of them
are
3d printed in their entirety others of
them are sort of
layered layered stacks
and there's some sort of technical
issues in terms of what you can and
cannot make
but essentially the the data you can
scan comes into three different
varieties so you can actually get quite
a rich signal just from one pulse
so even with one pulse you could for
example encode
like this grey code structure so this is
you know literally layers of sandwiched
together thin
film and it has this sort of gray code
physically encoded into it
and just with one pulse you can actually
get recover the sort of x y
location so that that's sort of where
your
where this beam is is penetrating this
physical object
so this is what it looks like on the
inside you have this
uh you know signal that goes through and
it reflects back
and you can basically encode this
information uh to get back the
the sort of the signal so you can see
where the where it goes through the
cover very clearly
and then this this wavy signal where
that comes out the other end
um and even a very very simple uh 3d
printed objects that just have these
the sort of basic you know geometry
inside of them
you can get some really interesting
signals back so
this is looking at how you know a series
of sort of inverted pyramids
uh gives you this this real time signal
back about
you know essentially you can derive
whereabouts they're located
underneath this the scanner so just like
a sort of
shift in the y direction uh you know
changes that signal from this sort of
short
uh reflection to a long reflection uh
and even even adding sort of random
voids inside of this object actually
gives you
you know some idea if you're doing an
entire scan of that object
uh you know of its obviously its
identity
but also it's its orientation within uh
a sort of known model
so you can look at you know there's a
bunch of the
air bubbles essentially we put inside of
this and then we can recover
uh those using that scanned data
so i think there's a some interesting
potential applications i mean obviously
like just just dealing with the whole
range of
you know near nearly similar but not
quite similar objects
and having to uh identify those is
really
interesting but i also think these
interesting things you can do if you can
see through uh
you know objects and like f you can
basically you can make something you can
identify it embed this code
uh and then see through to what's on the
other side uh would be really
interesting
um and also just being able to you know
identify these objects in more sort of
day-to-day
you know scenarios what if your little
robot wants to pick up your toys
i can figure out the ones and where they
go so there's a bunch of different uh
limitations to this obviously this
this this technology is like super
immature and it's it's it's very
very expensive um and some funny
interactions happen when you
when you get like 3d 3d printed objects
that have this
sort of periodic structure that's very
similar to the wavelength of this
electromagnetic radiation that you're
putting into it so you get
some weird attenuation and so some
materials you know don't work as well as
others
and overall the materials like the index
refraction and that's what this relies
on to get a really good signal
is pretty similar for all the all of
these different 3d printed materials so
they're all sort of
polymers you know plastics so
just using them by themselves is not you
know is not ideal
having little tiny little defects is
actually turns out to be the best
the best way so
uh you know in summary i think i think
this whole work is really about
you know ways we can build up this
toolkit of
you know things for uh techniques for
displays
and techniques for sensors uh techniques
for elimination and
techniques also for for tagging these
objects and i think that's
it's really interesting to see how we
can build this toolkit and to
now enable people to make these uh more
complicated and
active objects in the future so uh
obviously
i think you know it's it's moving
towards that direction of how do we make
how do we make a a fully you know 3d
printed device that
contains all this interesting
uh functionality uh so right now um just
to
skip back to i'm actually in autodesk
and and we're um
to have this new facility that our ceo
opened up
and this is him like cutting the ribbon
uh in san francisco this is like
in pier nine and uh they kind of made
this big middle ribbon and he's like a
kind of real
you know maker guy he likes making stuff
so anyway we basically open up this
facility and we're really
uh interested in working with other
people and looking at how we can you
know use these manufacturing and
fabrication tools
uh you know whether that's sort of high
really expensive like
cnc mills or um you know water jet
water jet cutters or lays and all this
kind of stuff laser cutters
uh 3d printers uh
and and see how we can you know
collaborate how we can figure out
what is going to be the sort of next
exciting thing that we can do with
with uh making you know the software
that's going to kind of drive all the
stuff
so um actually there's even a test
kitchen so if you're interested
if you're interested in cooking as well
you know we can do that as well so uh
there's a whole bunch of stuff it's it's
a
it's a pretty fun playground if you're
interested in coming and checking it out
do let me know
um so that's that's uh pretty much me
and uh welcome to to have any questions
so i have some samples um if anyone
wants to
check them out you're welcome to like
come up and have a look
um yeah as i said like there's some that
are quite easy to see uh i have a little
light here and you can like put some of
these on your iphone and actually see
the sort of
the the quality you get i guess and the
and the sort of the resolution you get
from
uh you know light going through 3d
printed ones
uh these guys you can open up and you
actually see what's inside but
from the outside it's kind of pretty
boring
the resolution seems like a major
bottleneck here
do you think that this is something that
the
hardware manufacturers are on and it's
going to get better
or is this something that's just going
to stick around until
you know people somehow figure out how
to how to lay these these things down
with more
precision yeah i mean i i think it's
it's
it's not dissimilar from photo
photography right that's used for
you know making chips right and that's
what is that down to like 20 something
nanometers now
so i mean that's that's kind of pretty
good
what's the resolution so i mean yeah
that's like an older magnet that's like
30 microns so it's it's you know
i mean there are 3d printers that i
think can be made like
for uh for doing like much
uh you know high resolution stuff the
thing is is that once you get
down like to those feature sizes it just
takes forever to
to make anything right so you can make a
tiny little thing that's a
high resolution which is fine if it's a
like a silicon chip right
but if you actually want to make a
really large thing that's gonna be like
super detail
is yeah you're just uh it's a scale
thing so
it would be the same i think if you're
doing you know if you're building a our
architecture
architecture building structure you just
don't need that
right so you need you need speed and you
need to better you know make that large
structure so
um but yeah i mean there's probably
gonna be some hybrid ways to do that
like
you know the outside can be high
resolution the inside can be low
resolution so
uh yeah sure in your example is the
illuminating elements so like a
led light or similar was always a
discrete component that you later
attached or
embed into the 3d printer is there
technology to actually uh
build that in like print the led
substrate yeah yeah the printed
electronics community is kind of
where where that stuff is happening so
yeah definitely but
but in terms of uh making
three-dimensional structures
with that no nothing nothing is
commercially available
yeah you mentioned having a process for
smoothing
uh the optics in low profile objects is
that some sort of post processing or
no that's actually in the machine so uh
in the paper it sort of describes it
more detail but essentially it's sort of
uh putting down material in such a way
we're sort of spraying it from a uniform
layer
uh and basically it sort of because it's
it's sort of
essentially if you if you allow the
material more time to cure if you don't
cure it straight away it sort of
smooths over and that's essentially like
how we did it inside of the machine
so yes
our innovations in this area considered
more
copyright or um are they considered
patents or what what's the nature of the
animation
uh me personally we're just in 3d
printing yeah in general
in general yeah three prints is a pretty
pretty aggressive uh
kind of curve going upwards of patterns
filed uh
so yeah there's definitely like a lot of
a lot of ip and there's
there's lawsuits that are kind of coming
about like in the last year
or a year and a half so people having
success with
copyrighting designs um
are people having successful copywriting
designs uh
yeah i haven't seen anything about
copyright too much and i guess
you generally hear the copyright
conversation with uh about
companies like disney for example um
you know like they're the ones i guess
who are more concerned
about it but to be honest i'm not like
super
super knowledgeable knowledgeable about
the copyright side of
i it one thing i was wondering is what
method you're using within it because
often in 3d printing you'll get a very
distinct layer of getting optical
clarity throughout
and maintaining that seems like it'd be
really big
machines right so i mean i think i think
it's a it's a difference between like
using
a liquid resin which is what we use and
using like a sort of thermoplastic
filament
so like that's like really discreet
layers where this is like basically sort
of
you know wets into that previous layer
so much that it's
it becomes clear at the end
oh no it's it's it's i don't think it's
i'm
saying at all but i'm not exactly sure
on the statistic but
um yeah it's it's it's not perfect i
mean
i think there's some yeah the clarity of
the
materials uh yeah there's
a whole bunch of things that make it
yellow for example like upon
exposure to uv light so that's kind of
effects
affects it but and it's also slightly
depends on the direction that you print
as well
so
yeah so i'm i'm reflecting a little bit
on the generativity of this approach
from many years when we had software
user interface design
let's say like java swing yeah um it was
sort of you would look at it and you
could sort of
copy and steal but you'd have to
re-implement and one of the major things
that i think changed the game with the
web
was essentially all design became open
source
html and css such that you could sort of
look at inspect extract and apply to
your own website
um it occurs to me that you know of
course if you have the files you can
recreate this yeah
you know especially if you're willing to
sort of destroy the thing you're looking
at
all designs here uh give it a high high
precision sensing instrument become open
source
yeah right like i can just take my uh
my little disney dude throw it inside of
like a high precision sander an optical
scanner
right and actually get something to go
which seems like it could
become a really interesting space for
people remixing
riffing on other people's designs i
copyright i'm sure it will be an
interesting question
yeah there's it seems like that that is
a potentially very open field
um right i i think the remix is
and that kind of stuff is happening more
in the digital realm right now like than
sort of people
using expensive hardware to figure out
like your design
um but yeah i mean i think that stuff
happens in with regular manufacturing
right now yeah i mean it's
yeah yeah i think i think that exists in
certain places
um so you know whether with a 3d
printing uh you know
accelerates that or not i'm not i'm not
entirely sure but uh yeah
it's it's a very good point
your thoughts questions oh yeah so
uh i'm sort of curious about this all of
the 3d printing
uh artifacts you showed are extremely
high precision
and they seem to be very scientifically
engineered
right and on the other hand you have
with woodworking for instance you have
craft people who just you know
decide oh i'm going to do this this way
because it feels right
to have this sort of right contour here
and do you do you see any of that
craft coming into 3d printing right i
mean i think i think it can come in
there but it's more
a matter of like the design tool you use
like it's more of a digital thing right
so it's like
you know sketching or or interacting
with that
side of it so basically it's yeah i mean
the end product is essentially
pretty well defined right so you have a
file and it goes to print and it comes
out like that but
i mean there's any number of processes
like people use this i mean
an example is like uh i think i sort of
talk at cs like by
legacy of legacy effects i believe and
they like they sort of
take the basic shell and then like they
cast that in silicon and they do a bunch
of other stuff and paint on top of it so
i mean
that's definitely there you can
definitely have those sort of
multi-layered processes
you